Hey bud, did you ever think that there's got to be more?
More than what?
The stuff we do, day after day.
Literally, not once.
Today's gonna be different, Goldie.
What are we looking at?
Who are you?
We ran into each other the other day.
How did you find me?
I waited outside by the murder train.
Guy, I have to tell you something.
There is no easy way to say this.
This world, it's a video game.
Buddy, if we're not real, doesn't that mean that nothing you do matters?
I am sitting here with my best friend trying to help him get through a tough time.
Now if that's not real, I don't know what is.
Milly, I know this world is just a game. But this place, these people, that's all I have.
Thanks, Guy.
Guy, in two days, the game is gonna shut down.